[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
end game class um a few weeks ago i did
a
class on essential end games for
beginner
for beginners excuse me and i kind of
wanted to follow up with that class
because
there are just so many technical end
games
that are so useful to know and so
important to know
and i wanted to go through some more of
those tonight
of course this is immediately following
the road 2000 lecture
on insane material imbalances if you
didn't catch that one
i would encourage you to go back and see
that because it was
a lecture with some really fun games
some of my favorite games
but in honor of that lecture i am going
to be going over
the most imbalanced endgame i can think
of that's still interesting
which is of course the queen versus pawn
end game and obviously this is one
that many of you may already know but i
think everyone would agree
this is one of the essentials and if you
do already know it
it can't hurt to have a little bit of a
refresher course on it
and i am going to introduce some pretty
fun puzzles at the end
so if you think you know these end games
well stick around
for the end and see if you can pass the
uh the little tests i have prepared for
you guys so
to start off with here we are looking at
this with the black pieces
in this case um and it's black to move
in this position
now don't be fooled uh if the pawns were
going this way
this would be the easiest win of all
time for black you just bring the king
in and win the game but here the pawns
are not going this way
the pawn is going this way and it's just
one little itty bitty step from making a
queen for
white and uh drawing the game of course
queen versus queen
you're never really going to be able to
outplay another person with such little
material on the board
so if black wants to win this game black
has to find some way
to stop this pawn so now i'm sure a lot
of people
in the chat are aware of the winning
strategy in this case
already but uh let's let's talk it
through how can
black ever try and win this
game against a pawn that is just one
step away
from queening how can we do it what do
you think chat
ariane has very enigmatically told me
the check procedure are you guys aware
of the check
procedure i'm assuming he is
not talking about the uh process by
which
a waiter or waitress will come to the
table take the check
bring it back wait for the card that
kind of thing although that
may be even more complicated than this
chess end game
so of course the idea as people
are mentioning here is that the queen
alone is actually not enough
to win any of these positions what do i
mean by that well
the king is always going to be able to
make threats
of promoting the pawn um
and the queen is never going to be able
to just stick somewhere and say all
right that's it
i have stopped this pawn from promoting
permanently now i can go about winning
the game
uh so the point is if you get to this
type of position and you just try to
check forever with the queen or try to
get in front of the pawn somehow
you're not going to make any progress
let's just take a look at that
and see if that is true so for example
queen f2 check king e8 check
check check if we check from the first
rank
king f7 we're never going to be able to
play a move like queen g8 blockading
this pawn
and getting it out of our way uh to win
the game
right that's just not going to happen so
what can we do how can we ever
win these positions right how do you
ever
win here how can you pin
no black will go here it's it seems as
if
black cannot ever win right we just
go around chasing each other in circles
for hours and hours and hours and the
second we try to step closer
white is going to queen so
how do we actually win well the point is
there's actually a bit of a trick
black can use to gain one move at a time
you can spend that one move to get your
king closer
and then when your king is super super
close to the pawn
you can just take with the queen and
your king's there for backup
and you can win the game that is the
essential idea
so what's the secret how do you gain
this extra time
to move your king closer well it turns
out
black can actually force the white king
to a very specific square
and the second the white king lands on
that square black can start to advance
his
own king closer what square is that
well of course it is the g8 square
whenever
the white king lands on g8 this is
black's prime opportunity
to step closer with the king why is that
well when the king is on g8 this pawn
obviously
cannot legally promote uh with its own
king
standing in the way so how do we
actually force the king to g8
well you start by bringing the queen a
little bit closer to
the king it turns out the queen
using its diagonal properties as well as
its forward-looking properties
can make some tangible threats against
both the king and the pawn
and those threats force the king back to
g8
so let's start by getting the queen as
close as we can white should actually
step
away from the pawn here which might not
be expected the point being if he steps
to g8 here
black steps closer so he wants to stay
away from the pawn
so that black no longer has time to do
this or else he'll be met
with queens so king e7 for example
we can step closer one rank at a time
king f7 queen f4 uh king g6
for example queen g4
king f6 or h6 would be a bit of a
mistake because then again
the black king can step closer we
haven't threatened a queen with white we
need the king to defend that square
so king h7 for example now queen
h5 check is stepping even even closer
and the king is forced back to the g8
square
if he goes this way for example trying a
bit harder we step
even closer with the queen king e7
and then what is the key move here what
is the key move here it's actually time
to stop checking the white king we want
to get
our queen as close as possible and now
we can no longer do that by giving
checks right these are only two real
useful checks
and neither of those advance the queen
closer so what's the big idea here
and yeah the chat room already has it
the idea is queen g6 stepping
even further up the board continuing our
little zigzag
and getting finally to the rank directly
behind
the pawn of course now white cannot
queen because the king had stepped away
from the pawn
and so king f8 is forced and now finally
the winning idea for black is you go
queen
f6 check and the point now is we are
giving the same check we've given a
million times before
but thanks to that thanks to the
diagonal power of the queen
we are also hitting this pawn on g7
white can no longer step away from the
pawn
or else it will be captured so king jade
is forced
now black can step closer with king uh
to e2 black white can try to escape
again
but it's not going to be any good uh
there are many ways
to get the king back to g8 now using the
same checking procedure
works just fine stepping back to the
file checks
right same idea
the exact same sequence there i know i
played through it pretty fast we give
this
check now king h6 or f6 doesn't work
because we can step closer
king h7 means queen h5 king steps to g8
between f7 means queen f5 the king
should step away
and now the key move again queen g6 the
exact same idea we saw before
and queen f6 check now it turns out
there is actually a bit of a faster way
to do this if you are curious
once you get the queen this close the
move queen f7
is actually much much faster and the
point now is
if king h6 then queen g8 is good also
the simple move king f3
and if king h8 we can immediately go
queen h5
and king g8 is going to be forced uh
once again
of course queening here is highly
illegal it won't even let me do it
because the pawn is pinned to the king
so we'll stick with this idea
and then we step even closer king f8
means this move
and the key move again here queen g6
queen f6 check and king g4 now
king h7 and here there's actually a very
interesting idea for black
you can go one step even closer
using the same ideas we just looked at
with
something like this but perhaps the
simplest
in this case is to just play this move
king to h5 and the point now is that
white is unable to queen due to
checkmate
and if white tries to make a knight and
be super tricky
queen f7 king h8 king g6
and now no matter where this knight goes
either checkmate and 1 will be played
like this or like this or 97 check
we have to capture but thankfully by
capturing we have given the king of
flight square
and we'll play checkmate but if you're
looking for
simplicity then the same pattern will do
you good here
king g8 king f5
and here if you want to get the king
even closer
you can play this move queen h6 pinning
the pawn to the king
king f7 for example you can go queen f6
check once again
king g8 king g6 and now the pawn
never even gets to promote you just take
and
win with your king as close as possible
so what did we just do from the starting
position
well we use this checking idea in this
key move of queen g6
using the diagonal power of the queen to
pressure both the pawn and the king at
the same time
and whenever the king steps in front of
the pawn and i mean whenever the king
steps in front of the pawn
we bring our king closer and closer and
closer
until eventually we can deliver
checkmate on the g7 square
so any questions about this idea before
we move on
to uh another example of it
no questions all right perfect no
questions and by the way
if you're one of those more beginner
level players who watches these lectures
and is a little bit too scared to type
in the chat
now's your chance this lecture this
lecture is not for chess king it's not
for aryan gutla it's for you
it's for the beginners out there
does pinning work better than king f8
okay so h h or a file so we are we're
going to go through
all the pawns on all the files don't
worry but for now let's stick with this
one
winning one questions about it here is
it for you great wolf i don't know do
you consider yourself to be a beginner
it's tough does pinning work better than
king f8 so i'm not entirely certain what
you're talking about
on aruda um
in general i was the only pins i was
mentioning
were these ideas um sorry not those
ideas
let's make that the main line uh
this idea of going uh queen f7 here
to pin the pawn to the king it is sort
of the fastest way
and so if you want to say better then
you can say queen f7 is faster
i wouldn't call it better because both
ways win
and if you really just want to stick
with the checking idea you are more than
welcome to do so with queen back to h4
and giving this check and getting back
to queen g6 like this
right and once again advancing the king
this is a perfectly fine way to do it
don't let anybody tell you that because
your way is slower
it is worse the best checkmate is always
the one that you see
so if you're confident with this then
you are confident with this
can i go over it again so we're going to
go over a very similar
situation here with the pawn on the
center of the board
and in fact some might say this is even
simpler
because you don't have to even think
about running out of space on the sides
of the board
as you would with a knight pawn
so this position is actually going to be
winning with the exact
same method that we just took a look at
we want to force
the king in front of the pawn and then
bring our king closer
step by step by step so how can we force
the king in front of the pawn
well it's the same idea as last time we
need the king
close to the king in the pawn so that
its diagonal powers will actually be
useful
right now its diagonal power is pretty
useless to us actually they don't really
do much there's no way
of these diagonal moves influencing the
king in the pawn
but the second we get super super close
we see that a queen
on d6 for example would pressure both
the d-file and the e-7 pawn
at the same time so we need to get close
how do we get close will we check the
king up the board
by the way in these positions you can
give this check to come further up
or you can actually just go queen e3 as
well
because you're stopping the pawn from
queening by defending it
king has to come back to defend we come
closer
say king c7 we can come closer king d7
now we can't come closer immediately or
else white would queen but we can give
this
check king c7 and then the key move here
once again
is stepping closer whenever we can
stopping the pawn from queening
and also forcing the king to the back
rank now and finally
queen d6 and we have achieved this
diagonal power
that we were looking for king c8 not
playable
because of queen takes e7 and so once
we're here
it becomes pretty simple we come forward
white must try to escape and we can go
back now
to the same ideas we were looking at
with these
checks right the king can step away but
we will step
forward and here
and queen e6 is the key idea once again
always stepping forward whenever
possible by the way the same pinning
idea that we looked at last time
does actually also work here with queen
d7
pinning the pawn to the king we can
check can can't step in front of the
pawn remember
and then queen back to e6 and bam
queen f6 check same predicament for the
white king
cannot step to the side so king e8 and
now king
c3 and at the end of the day
at the end of the day
black is going to get the queen or sorry
going to get the king
right up close and personal
and win the game the same
idea we've seen before queen e6 the key
move then queen
f6 forcing the king to make a decision
has to step in front of the pawn
now king c5 will say
king d7 we can even just go queen d6
check immediately
king e8 um
i guess king c6 might be the simplest
now bringing the king as close as
possible
and finally at the end of the day
we have five check king eight
king d6 only one legal move for
whites and we can give checkmate so the
tricky bits
usually happen around here when the king
is super super close
and here you just have to rely on a
little bit of calculation
i don't think it's worth trying to
memorize what to do exactly with the
king
when you get this far just try and
calculate a little bit the only thing
you have to look out for
well number one of course is not letting
them queen for free
and number two is making sure you do not
do not do not still meet the white king
as there is some potential for that here
for example the worst move on the board
bar none is king to oh sorry
this move is technically the worst move
on the board this move is also pretty
bad
but king c7 is a close third
with stalemate on the board i always
have to
be sure i'm telling the truth when i say
worst move on the board otherwise people
will be sure to correct me
so king c7 would be pretty bad with
stalemate king
d6 though would win the game giving the
king a square
with checkmate to follow so once again
any questions on this technique
any questions on this technique
so az says this technique would be very
difficult to apply it and blitz with
five seconds on the clock
well luckily in time scrambles you don't
have to try to win the pawn
you just have to try to check the white
king as many times until your opponent
runs out of time
if you play this endgame perfectly is
there an initial position where you draw
due to the 50 moves rule
absolutely not you are always able to
get to the pawn in time in fact i'm
showing
sort of the absolute worst examples with
the king here
on the a1 square
what's the exact
it looks like i do have a table base
here it looks like with the king on a1
the distance to capturing the pawn or
checkmate is
44 half moves which is 22 moves so much
time to spare
all rights so then
let us move on to the other type
of this kind of end game so far we have
seen what happens
with the pawn on the quote-unquote
knights file meaning the g-file and the
ideas here are the same as the pawn
on the b file because the chessboard is
symmetric the ideas don't really change
we've seen what happens with the e pawn
and of course here the ideas are going
to be exactly the same
for the d-pawn it changes literally
nothing the chessboard being symmetric
once again takes care of that
but now what happens with the
bishop's pawn this one is a little bit
more complex
and actually i lied we're going to look
at that next first let's look at what
happens
with the rooks pawn this pawn being
on a rook file meaning either the h file
or the a file
and the idea is again sort of transfer
because the chessboard
supersymmetric and what happens here
what do you guys think can black win
this position is there something wrong
with our technique
so yeah of course the same technique is
not going to work here white
is actually in a bit of a fortress it's
impossible
to win this position if white plays it
well
and white doesn't even have to play it
that well i can usually just sort of
you know play only moves and then and
then draw the game
so why doesn't the same idea work well
let's go ahead and try it let's get our
queen
up close and personal to the
white king it turns out we can actually
force him
to uh step to the h8 square
but the problem is the second the king
steps to h8
we cannot actually advance our king why
is that
well because the game has just ended in
a stalemate of course
the king runs out of squares in the
other examples we looked at
this would be the point where the king
steps one square to the right
and we check him back in front of the
pawn advance our king further
and then we would continue doing so
until our king is super close
however here we only get to play one
king move and then the game ends
by stalemate and there's actually just
no tricky way around this you can't even
try to trick the opponent
into you know it not being stalemated
it's always
going to be a stalemate here and
for example you can never really get
this position with the queen on a square
like
h6 for example or e6 because you just
can't force the king
to h8 for example
um let's say you get this position and
play queen e6 check
here if king h8 is played then that
would be great you can come forward you
can step
up in advance but white can play either
king g7 or king f8 neither of these
moves are bad
and both of them threatened a queen
meaning black can make no progress
right and if you get this position
let's say somehow you get
this position with the queen on h6 well
then black and
white can simply promote right you know
it'd be great if he was forced to move
the king here uh
in either direction then black would be
able to make progress or take the pawn
but of course white can simply queen and
so
i will say in the normal case where the
black king is super far away
this end game is going to be a draw and
we're going to look at the exceptions to
that a little bit later in the lecture
and that's where things get a bit
complicated
but this is the simple version right in
general when the black king is far away
these end games are always going to be a
draw
if the pawn is on the a file or the
h file and once again we're gonna take a
look at some exceptions
to this idea but
first let's talk about the bishop's pawn
so what is going on with the bishop's
pawn
it seems like yeah obviously you know
the rook pawn there's these weird things
where you run out of board space and the
king gets stalemated
but surely surely we would be able to
win
with the f-pawn where is shirley
somebody gets shirley no never mind
okay why can't we win against a bishop
on i'm revealing the answer you cannot
win here
but why is that the case why bishop
pawns it seems so random right like
knight pawns are winning center pawns
are winning
rook pawns they're weird who cares but
bishop pawns surely we could win
surely we could win against the bishop
pawns but i guess not
and yeah the chat already knows the
uh the issue here is that
this this darned h8 square still manages
to get
itself involved regardless of whether we
want it to
or not and so once again the king is
going to run out of space
on the h file how does this happen well
let's start by getting our queen closer
as we have in the past
king h7 for example uh
previously queen f6 here is the key move
getting the queen closer whenever
possible
but now king g8 queen g6 and
historically
this has been where white either goes
away from the pawn and loses the pawn
or steps in front of the pawn and we
advance with the king
however in this case after king h8
our idea that we relied on is being able
to capture the pawn in this case
and if we capture the pawn this stupid
h8 square is involved again
and this is in fact stalemate and it's
sort of
one of the great crimes against chess
that black has no way to make any
progress here
but black has no way to make any
progress here it seems super unfair
i know right like you've got this queen
all this guy's got this one little pawn
all you need to do is bring your king
but this one stalemate trick there's
there's just no way to get around it
it's sort of ridiculous
so once again in this simple case
when the black king is super far away
this position is going to be
just a dead draw there's no way to make
progress here
white will always step to the corner and
never step in front of the pawn
if he knows what he's doing of course if
he doesn't know what he's doing then you
might still have a chance to win this
game with this idea you know they might
get scared of going king h8 play king f8
and then you step
closer with the king as you have in the
past
so useful to know is the defender as
well king h8 the drawing idea
with the bishop's pawn and once again
this is completely symmetric on the
other side of the board
the king would step to a8 in the same
stalemate idea
would be appearing okay though
let's start talking about all of the
nuances
with the rook pawn all right so in the
first case
we looked at the rook pawn uh
in this case with the king way back here
on d1
and the rook pawn up here on h7 but
taking a look here
things are a little bit different right
there's a big difference between d1 and
d5
for this king so chatroom do you know
the answer to this one
is d5 close enough for black to win
this game or do we need to be a little
bit closer
just a little bit closer you tell me can
black win here
and then i will go into some of the
explanation
as to why and this is something that
i've actually seen explained before
but it was very confusing uh when i saw
other people explain it so
i'm going to give you a sort of new idea
here see if it helps
gray wolf has a great little mnemonic
device if you put
the h a c f files together
it almost spells half as in half point
for draw
if only the c was an l but you know
close enough it's a fun one
something i have not seen before
okay and finally our super strong chat
room is divided
chess king says yes then he says wait no
peter pearson said peter peterson says
probably one step too far away
chalene says you're close enough chess
king says king on d4 is a draw
danilo says he'd say no but he's also
bad
good to know dinesh says can't win sahil
says
it's a draw believe it or not black is
completely winning
again well as long as it's black to move
of course if it's white to move white
makes the queen
but black to move this position is
totally
totally winning why is that
well historically when i've seen this
explained people have highlighted
all these squares and said yeah if your
king is on any of these squares
then you win the game right but i think
that's silly how are you going to
remember
what is this 9 squares plus 14
8 how are you going to remember 18
squares right that's ridiculous
so what i remember is if the king
can step to one of these four squares
for black
then black is going to be winning
um and this i think is a better way to
remember it
because black has checkmating ideas if
the king can get to
any of these squares and those
checkmating ideas win the game
so if you remember at the beginning of
the lecture i briefly mentioned you know
black can be sort of fancy and just
checkmate
white right off the bat with the king
being this close rather than just trying
to directly win the pawn
and now black actually has to rely on
being fancy because his king is so far
away
so chat how do we actually win how do we
get to one of these squares
and win the game does anybody know
the does anybody know the line here
for black
grey wolf says oh look corresponding
squares not quite
not quite historically that's like all i
use these circles for let's uh
now this one is nothing to do with
corresponding squares
so yeah lane foster has the right first
move of course going here immediately
does nothing
white just queens and then you know what
is our queen doing out here
check he's running check he's blocking
and white is safe right
so we obviously need the queen a little
bit more involved than it is on d1
so the right way to start is this move
queen g4
check now white has a couple options you
can go this way or he can go this way
and really it doesn't matter so much
what he does with the king
we're going to play sort of the same
move in response king d7
means queen d7 check i believe
um and king h8 is also going to mean
queen d7 actually king h8 is probably a
bit worse we should probably go king f7
with this king um and then
yeah i was a bit inaccurate here queen
d7 is fine but king g6
is going to delay us quite a bit so we
need a better move
than queen d7 of course it's going to be
the same idea that we've seen
historically where we inch the queen
closer with queen f5
king g7 queen over to g5
and now king h8 is actually a bit of a
mistake uh and we'll see why in a little
bit but let's stick with king f7 for now
and sorry um and after king g7 actually
okay with the queen on f5 we've gotten
the queen close enough
and now we can enact our checkmating
idea i'm sorry i'm so so sorry
so now finally black can step to e6 with
the queen on f5
when white queens guess what this move
is czech king f8 for example
means queen e7 check queen f7 mate
and king h7 means the absolutely
stunning move
king f7 and this is a position
you should remember well because this is
the key idea
for black to win black steps to the
f7 square and now believe it or not
there are no checks for white that are
useful
all of them are covered by the king and
the queen
and there's no way to stop checkmate
either there's no way to stop it
if the queen escapes queen
g6 oh sorry well this is checkmate in
one i saw this one
but yeah checkmate and one is pretty
good as well and yeah that's it that's
the game
there's no stalemates actually that one
would be still made but we take with the
king
so there is one stalemate but you just
take with the king
queen f8 check you take back with the
king and and it's over
so how do we get here we start with
queen g4 check
king f7 we go queen f5 check king g7
and now king e6 and we have this killer
idea
of queen g5 king f7 winning
the game now what happens if king h8 i
said this one was a little bit wrong
well here we can actually just transpose
back to what we had immediately with
queen f5 and king e6
there's also queen d7 here with the idea
of an early king e6
and check made on f7 but simplest is
probably to stick with the idea that we
know
which is queen f5 and king e6
and queen g5 check the key move here
with king f7 to follow really really
cool stuff
so that's why stepping to either of
these squares
is enough for black to win the game
because from either of these squares you
can get to f7
and that's the critical idea that wins
the game for black getting to f7
with this mating net is the key point
so why do these two squares also work
you obviously can't get to f7 from here
it's a bit too far away
but of course the chessboard symmetry is
coming to bail us out once again
not only is stepping to f7 enough but
stepping to g6
is enough to win as well so for example
if we had this position
if i can triangulate here okay black to
move in this position
right once again these are the squares
we need to get the king to in order to
win
the king can step to f5 from e4 so this
is going to be a winning position as
well
by the exact same idea
only in this case we need to put our
queen
on the e6 square
rather than the f5 square that we saw
last time so how can we go about doing
that
well queen d8 check king g7 for example
sorry king f7 for example
um no sorry king g7 for example is a bit
better and once again there are multiple
ways to do this
but if we stick with the idea we know we
can do this
queen here and now king f5 and it's the
exact same thing
only with the position of the queen and
the king reversed
promote to a queen once again this idea
doesn't work
to check and mate and this idea runs
into king g6
okay so this is the pretty complicated
one this is complicated stuff here i'm
not going to lie
but the key thing to remember
right going to the initial position
black is winning if his king is in this
box
because he can step to these four
crucial squares
that win the game for black why are
these four squares crucial
because we can set up this idea of
putting the king on g6
with checkmate to follow right or g6 or
f7 with checkmate to follow why
isn't d4 winning well d4 isn't close
enough for the king
because of course the king cannot get to
any of these squares that's why we get
these
this weird sort of asymmetry where these
squares are all close enough
but d4 is not
not good enough for the black king
okay so questions on this questions on
this there should be questions here
because this is complicated
[Music]
so chalene if you take a look earlier in
the lecture i explained
why when the king is super far away this
one is not winning
because white of course can still mate
himself in the corner
please stop touching my face can't help
it force a habit
also that's not a question
what if more than one pawn versus the
queen stay tuned for the puzzles at the
end of the lecture learner's point
why can't we follow the same zigzag
checkmate technique with the rook pawn
earlier in the lecture i promise i
covered that once again
uh i will very very briefly go over it i
don't want to repeat myself too much
but the point here is that we cannot do
the zigzag because
when we get close
here when the king steps in front of the
pawn we cannot step
up because the white king is stalemated
right okay
let's move on then from the rook pawn
once again
these four squares are the key squares
the king needs to reach
if the king is close enough to step to
one of those squares
then the square of course included in
our little
perimeter here then black is winning
with this idea
of putting the king sorry
that's not the right move king g4 check
with this idea of putting the queen on
the opposite square right putting the
queen on the opposite square
very quickly though i do want to take a
look at some
what happens for example if the king is
here sorry not here
even as far as here right
now the king cannot step to e6 but it
can step to e7
and the winning technique is going to be
exactly the same right
it does not matter that the square is a
little bit more awkward
unable to reach the comfortable square
of e6 you can still go queen f5
and king e7 and there's no practical
difference between
these two squares for black because the
square we really cared about was f7 the
whole time
right it's exactly the same winning idea
wanted to mention that as well
so one last time these squares are
important because from them
black is able to reach f7 or g6
and i think sometimes getting to these
squares might work but that's a little
bit silly because why would you put
yourself in a square
where your opponent can promote with
check no reason to do that and from any
square where you can touch these squares
you can also touch the squares one file
back just by the nature of the
chessboard
so black wins on this perimeter because
you can touch these two critical squares
and from there you can get to f7 or g6
that's the idea
that's the idea now
let's take another look at the bishop
pawn
okay so who knows some rules
about the bishop pawn this one is even
more complex i would say
than the rook pawn for when black is
going to be winning with the king
the trick is somehow different with the
bishop pawn well there's sort of just
more tricks to understand which makes
things a little
bit complicated
if king h8 then draw well
it's a bit it's a bit more complicated
than that
so what is the evaluation of this
position sorry i was catching up with
chat and i forgot to tell you guys
what what i was asking um sort of just
getting acclimated with the position
itself
aniruddha doesn't know yet which is
perfectly fair people are suggesting a
move
which is also perfectly fair but there's
no evaluation i don't know if they think
it's winning or not
um i have is saying that this is a draw
but then he's saying never mind
so black to move i'm sorry black black
to move here
learners point says draw question mark
so this one is
actually going to be a victory and the
idea is going to be very very similar
you want to step
closer with our king so king f5 here
right now if white's only two legal
moves or king g7 or kg8 let's say king
g8
is his choice and now the point is after
queen g5 check
the drawing idea was to step away from
the pawn
pointing out that we can queen or you'll
have to put us
in stalemates right by capturing
but thankfully here black can do better
so
black to move and win and this position
this is the key
key point
black to move and win
and yeah the chatroom has it you have to
go king
g6 in this position and we have another
tricky tricky checkmate
white now queens and there's even a
little bit of separation between the
queen and the king
but we have now checkmate thanks to the
move queen h4 or
queen h5 and queen h7 when this queen
is a traitor and has blocked the king
put him in a little coffin
so that this is actually going to be
checkmate with no
escape route available to him so
uh in order to win on the with the
bishop pawn
we need to be able to reach g6
to uh to win the game so what does this
mean
well let me set up the position with
white to move
sorry with white to move here
it means that this position is actually
going to be a draw
if it's white to move because white
steps out of the way
we don't have time to get to g6 and as
soon as we start checking
then king h8 and this idea is going to
be good king g7 or king g5 rather is not
enough
f8 queen check and the king is escaping
and we don't like the king escaping our
king is too far away
so this starting position is winning
because we can get to g6
right the key is being able to get to g6
now do we care about this other side of
the board do we care if our king can get
to e6
for example what happens on the long
side of the board this is the king on
the short side
the the key square on the short side is
to get to g6
but what about this long side who knows
about the long side of the board well
let's take a look let's take a look
at the long side of the board and see
what is going on
here so black to move and win
is the king close enough well i guess i
just told you the king is close enough
and let's take a look at what happens
here and oh my goodness thank you so
much
sean for the ten dollars in the chat
that is too kind too kind of you
what's wrong with queen h6 and king g6
first let me take a quick look and then
we'll get back to it
uh let's say here here here here
yeah this is this is also perfectly fine
with queen h7
also perfectly fine chess king okay back
to this one so it turns out
that the black king is actually close
enough
and the reason is not the e6 square as
you might expect on the other side it
was g6 so it might make sense to think
that it was the e6 square but black is
winning here because he can get to the
e7 square
this is the key point we go king d6 king
g8
and now after check white either has to
block his pawn which is an easy win that
we've seen before
or step away and now we have the key
idea of going king e7 and stopping this
pawn
with our king while the queen keeps the
king out of play
so in general on the short side of the
board
you can get to g6 and play for this
checkmating idea
and if your king is on the other side of
the board getting to e7
is going to be enough for a win
and now you know this would be about i
think equally as complicated
as the um the ideas with the rook
pawn you know it's still this check
mating idea or on the other side of the
board you can't really play for
checkmate because white runs away
but you can get to e7 and stop the pawn
but there's one more
critical idea with the bishop pawns
to to think about and that brings me to
the last
uh oh sorry the first puzzle of the
night and the most difficult puzzle but
i wanted to give it to you guys
black to move what's the evaluation of
this position
and what is the best line
black to move here what's the evaluation
of this position
this is a bit complicated for beginners
well i wanted to sort of cover this
pretty thoroughly here pretty thoroughly
so the beginning part that's what's
important for super super beginners
but this part is also pretty interesting
and if you can understand this
then you understand everything i think
about these queen versus single pawn end
games
chess king says draw cat wi-fi says king
b5 or a queen move
i have says win for black well how
you guys got to explain here i just
finished telling you the g6 square is
important
not going to get there and the e7 square
is important
probably not going to get there either
right so
how on this planet is black
going to win this position
right one move is not enough here one
move is not enough
need a winning line and now
this one is complicated enough and i
don't want to spend the rest of the
lecture
just sitting here waiting for the chat
to figure it out so if you guys are in
the chat right now
thank you guys so much for thinking
about this puzzle i would very much
actually encourage you
to go ahead and pause here even if
you're watching live and try to figure
this one out because it's worth thinking
about
and actually as i'm saying that someone
in the chat does have it so if you do
want to think about it more i encourage
you to pause right here it's a really
beautiful idea
but black is actually winning in this
position how is black winning well black
is winning
with the idea king b5 now what
you know you're saying you're saying to
yourself like what what are you talking
about king b5
how that's not like of course getting
the king closer is nice but like what
does this matter
well it matters because immediately
white cannot get
to this other side of the board so what
should white do well white should try
and promote his pawn
right king e8 try to promote and now
if black goes back sort of the usual
business here and tries to check the
king
now white should actually believe it or
not run to the king's side of the board
if black tries to get closer then the
idea we looked at king g8
is good enough for a draw black is not
getting to e7 and
white can still mate himself in the
corner and draw the game
however black can do better in this
position
than something like the usual queen e3
check and bringing the king closer
and how can black do better i can do
better with the critical move
queen to g6 now if king f8
king c6 and the point is white cannot
come
stalemate himself in the corner because
this queen very crucially
is guarding the g file still
so king f8 not playable but king e7
seems playable
and now finally the critical idea again
is queen
g7 pinning the pawn to the king king
e8 and then black to move and win here
uh we're not gonna go for repetition
we're not gonna give this
check allowing white to go for this
stalemating idea again
we play the move king c6 and after
queens
queen d7 is checkmate
and that is the beautiful idea that
allows black to win this position
so there's one more little rule for you
guys that i want to keep in mind
that i want you to keep in mind if black
is stopping white from getting to the
corner for the stalemating idea
black is winning if and only if he can
get
to the c6 square obviously these squares
also get the job done as they are closer
but c6 is the square that's critical for
black
if white cannot reach the h8
square so that is just an
extra little puzzle for you guys to to
figure out there
hopefully you guys enjoyed that i do
have one or two more puzzles for you
guys if we have the time
here's a puzzle with the rook pawn so
um obviously we saw that it was a draw
when
there was one rock pawn on the board but
now
i have introduced the idea of a second
pawn so black to move and win in
this position black to move and win here
what do you think
i'm not going to ask you the evaluation
obviously black is winning somehow
otherwise i wouldn't show the puzzle
so black to move and win what do you
think chat
black to move and win let's let's hear
some ideas okay one idea is king c5 king
c5 has been thrown out
i just hovered over a few moves by the
way don't worry about those
some of them are correct some of them
are not
king c5 has been thrown out if the pawn
was on a rank below
then queen b3 queen c2
queen c1 would win i think
you are mixing up the coordinates a bit
you're thinking about queen g6 i think
rather than queen b3
zigzag the queen zigzag the queen has
been suggested queen f1
x claim or queen f5 x claim has been
suggested so let me throw a wrench in
the works here fellas alright and ladies
fellas and ladies there's only one
winning move
there's only one winning move okay
actually only one way to win this
position
which seems paradoxical at first right
you might not expect that
so the winning idea can be discovered by
examining a similar position so
i will introduce that position next but
here i want to show you guys
what the main idea is so queen g6
actually doesn't get the job done
white is just going to be promoting this
pawn and there's absolutely nothing you
can do about it right
the best you can do is come take the guy
let's say by some miracle white even
plays okay
you can't make white play king h8
otherwise it's checkmate and that is the
real idea
but you know by some miracle even if you
won this pawn for free
it would still be a draw thanks to the
rook pawn
on h7 and the king being too far away
right we're not
going to get to those critical squares
we're not in our perimeter here
and so it would be a draw but the idea
of queen f5
actually is going to be enough to win
here the point now
is if a7 queen to f8 is
a checkmate but
you know white can try a bit harder with
king g7
however black can still weasel his way
in here with queen g5
check let's say if
king 2h8 then it gets really really
simple
really really quickly
and finally white is stalemated on the
king's side
but this pawn is now playing for black
see a7
and queen f8 mate and if king f7 here
then the winning move is actually the
same idea
we've seen show up in other versions of
this end game
we use the kings the queen's diagonal
powers to force the king in front of the
pawn
because now you know we're not forcing
the king in front of the pawn and
stalemating it
we're forcing the king in front of the
pawn taking advantage of the a pawn and
checkmating it so queen h6 using the
diagonal ability of the queen
is enough king g8 queen g6 check
king h8 to keep the pawn queen f7
and mate by the way if the king comes
this way
it's never going to be enough you're
never getting over here to this pawn
you can stop it in its tracks so this
position is winning with queen f5
now i hear you guys at home you're
saying wait wait a second
if queen f5 is winning what the heck
dude why not queen
f1 it's the same idea you just weasel
your way up there and then you win the
game right
wrong incorrect king g7 draws the game
here
if you try this idea king
f7 is going to be the move you try to
keep coming up the board king g7
queen g4 check and now
white to move and draw
who sees white to move and draw here
this is the reason why this is the
reason why
this is not the way to go
and yeah the idea as peter peterson says
in the chat
is not king h8 when you would be running
into this exact same problem of queen f5
this is actually the same position as if
you had played queen f5 on move one
but king h6 is believe it or not the
drawing idea
what's the point well generally when the
king would run so far away
we could put the queen in front of the
pawn like this
and sort of laugh in his face for
example i guess this would be the most
accurate way to do it preventing
king g7 but now a7 and if we go queen h8
believe it or not now this is a draw why
is this a draw
white to move and draw again who knows
who understands
yes you stopped me from playing uh
you blockaded my pawn successfully good
job
but as we're already over time i'm going
to ask you guys at home to pause if you
want to figure it out
the idea is white king queen
we take this guy king g7 and uh-oh
now the stalemate tricks are back white
has sacrificed this pawn
and the position is drawn if we tried to
be tricky and play
queen uh f4 check hoping for king g7
queen g5
eliminating king h6 white goes king g6
in this idea this idea of a7
and a8 sacrificing the pawn is now
unstoppable
so really interesting position here
queen f5 wins the game
queen f1 does not because white has this
very clever idea
of coming to the sixth rank and drawing
the game
in that manner i wanted to ask you guys
about one
more type of position which i'm going to
just put on the board manually here
let's say
you end up in
a position where
you have your king super far away but
the pun's not on the seventh the pawn's
on the sixth
can you win this position question for
the chat here
final question and this is a bit easier
than the last one the last one was a
pretty tough puzzle
from which book are these puzzles what
do you mean from which book
the book of my brain um
yeah i actually i did come up with these
puzzles myself that's not to say
they haven't ever been invented before
probably they have because there's only
two pieces on the board
and it's tough to do anything original
with two pieces on the board
but i did come up with these on my own
for what it's worth
so learner's point asks what if there
are two or more connected passers versus
the queen
in general those positions are always
going to be winning
uh the reason these are sometimes drawn
with one pawn
are these stalemate tricks uh with two
connected pawns as long as they aren't
on the seventh obviously
then the queen can usually blockade get
in front of the pawns and once the queen
is in front of the pawns
it's sort of hopeless for white
obviously there are exceptions but
as long as you get the queen in front of
the pawns then the pawns are usually
immediately immobilized
and the game is over so danilo says yes
you need to put the queen
on a eight and that is pretty
much close to the truth however there's
one more idea that we can borrow
from the previous puzzle that will make
our winning task
all the much more easy so for example if
queen d7 check
king b8 for example queen b5 check
king a7 would allow us to bring the king
closer
and then win the pawn so if king b6
trying a bit harder to hold on to this
pawn then
queen c8 a7 doesn't draw because we can
blockade the pawn
and for example here queen c7 king a8
now it is actually going to be matan 2.
black plays any legal king move
and then a7 queen c8 checkmate
is a great idea so easy win
for black if the pawn isn't on the
seventh rank in this case
right uh there's no stalemates for white
and instead
white will be in zugzwang and have to
move the king away to the a8 square
or allow the queen to the a8 square and
once the queen is on a8 if i can find
this line again
uh b6 for example queen here a7 a8
now it's simple there's never threats of
queening the pawn and we
bring the king up at our leisure and
take the guy for free
all right any final questions on these
queen versus pawn end games i think i
covered almost everything there is to
cover
if not everything there is to cover
about these things hopefully you guys
have a good understanding now of how to
win these end games
and maybe at least are a little bit
aware
of these more complicated cases where
the pawn has some tricky business or the
king is just barely close enough to
catch that pawn
and give checkmate any final questions
for me before we call tonight here
all right well in that case i am going
to
call it quits here for the youtube
channel thank you guys so much for
joining me for these two lectures this
wednesday night the fun will continue on
the twitch channel with analyze your
games the class where i
analyze your games makes sense
uh but if you're watching the uh video
version
the the rerun version thank you again
for watching
i have had a lot of fun showing you guys
these uh
puzzles and these ideas in queen versus
pawn end games
that's it for me here tonight thank you
for watching and i will see you next
[Music]
time
you